at this point yesterday i was
introducing our first in-studio guest in
over 13 months
and boy did he just uh make up made up
for lost time
in terms of energy in terms of content
in terms of bringing it his a game
steven a smith all i merely asked him at
one point was like do you miss being a
uh
uh uh writing do you like the written
word he was he was a writer and a
columnist and a sports
reporter in philadelphia before
everything that we've seen him become
today
and then he went off on the dallas
cowboys for 10 straight minutes
including michael irvin
who he circled back at the very end to
just drop the mic
talking about his suits in his hair my
gosh so of course i have to have equal
time to my guy he's
my guy he's my my man my colleague
i love this man so i have to give him an
opportunity he's my
receiver he's michael irvin here on the
rich eisen show how are you irv
great i'm doing well rich say hey thanks
for having me on again rich and rich
i watched that that was insane
last night i mean we're in the middle of
so much going on
and for stephen a to spew that much
just just disdain towards the fan base
of the dallas cowboys yes
it was it's like we're in
april april
it was amazing to me it was amazing yeah
well he said that you uh appearing on
first take that time where you needed
the towel to tie yourself off was the
most fun he's ever had on first take
number one in the history of first take
is what he said right
right in the midst of all of that uh
uh thing he got for the cowboys fans he
still had his greatest moment
right there because that's the kind of
energy of course any kind of love we
have
for our team and he's right rick that
was fun
that was insane it was crazy you know
having that moment over there it it
would have not it would have been
much better that we won that game like
you know
like he said you know hey we won that
game but but even in that
don't let him spew that time i heard
every something always
happened you know it it something always
happened to 31 other teams
it's only one team that wins the
championship and
and right now the cowboys of course
right now
have a good chance as anybody to be in
sofa
that is true that is true but he says it
doesn't matter like
i think he said yeah he said that he
wants you to
be in sofi or get to sulfide just so you
know
he wants you to go to 16. great
yes so yeah that that's what he said
that that's what he said
but but but he he really don't even want
us having that great success because
he's afraid
that well well he really thinks it's not
going to happen
but i'm telling you i'm telling you with
that and fold
and we're back we're back to being with
the defense now
playing a defense that the players know
the scheme that the talented
if you just give me the defense the
dallas cowboys had two years ago
with what doc was doing at the beginning
of last
year yeah i i think the cowboys have
been a pretty good spot
so why do you think he dislikes cowboys
fans so much michael
and then likes to likes to make fun of
you and have fun with you
michael well you you you know what it is
rich what does it mean
this is thing that has has shattered
everything you've done he wrote in
philadelphia you were talking about
writing he was writing in philadelphia
after we spank a like a bank of that
booty all the time over there in philly
especially through the years that he was
most prominent right there
you know what i mean and then he goes to
new york and we're spanking like a bank
in that booty
and he's there and all he hears is how
great the cowboys are
and they're america's team and
everywhere you go you can't escape it
if you can't escape it then you start
hating it
it's in everything he does he can't
escape it
and now his great asset that has been
the dallas cowboys to help him get
to this place of prominence becomes a
great liability because everywhere he
goes
we are there and we make sure he knows
we
are there so because tj that's your
theory right that
that that that you and irv are kind of
locked step in right what your theory is
that
i feel like stephen a is a as a closet
cowboy fan because
you can't talk about something as much
as he does
and really hate it otherwise you just
ignore it after a certain point right
but yeah that's my whole point that's my
whole point
he can't ignore it see see now no matter
where he goes with the fan base being so
wide and spread everywhere it it knows
and knows about this thing that he has
everywhere he goes
it will come again it will rise again
you know you can't say like okay when
you're
you you some places you can go on
yourself i gotta worry about no cowboy
fans here
that place doesn't exist that's why it's
america's team
and then that thing lingers over them
you see what i mean there is no hiding
from it
and when you can't hide from it you have
to learn to live with it
and when you learn to live with it now
you got to just try to always
battle it and that's what he does that's
what he does he wishes
what he really wishes out is that his
teams
were like this he wishes that he
was on the upper head but he knows it's
the cowboys
and it'll always be the cowboys and
there's nothing they can do about it
well his point is that
and so at one point michael irving here
on the rich hazard show at one point
um he said that you know he suggested
doing something in the cowboys stadium
and espn said well we can't get you in
there and i think that might have been a
a coveted situation and he said doesn't
care he just needs a parking lot
he just wants the parking lot just so he
could be there and just and just get
get in the face of all the cowboys
friends just even in the parking lot and
i was like well
actually the cowboys friends should want
you there because
at some point it's going to happen and
they're going to want to actually
see him and see him in person and give
him the business in person and he said
that'll never happen
essentially yeah yeah and and you know
he's already offered if
we win he wants to emcee the parade and
all of that stuff you know what i'm
saying
there there's something in that even
when he's saying that
he wants to emcee the parade
and then he thought that that was going
to be some form of security to me
i was like wait a minute i didn't i tell
you what if the cowboys win what you do
is put on a dallas cowboy maid outfit
and come clean my whole house
i have with him that's the bit we put on
on his show
on his new show you know what i don't
know
i said i wanna hear you i'm see a parade
you're going you're gonna take over
daphne's job my girl
that mr debbie you sit down steven a and
we're gonna make a dallas
cowboy outfit for him to walk around
there did
and you know and i'ma certainly harass
him i'm gonna tell you right now
you'll just drop stuff all over the
place and say pick that up pick it up
clean that up oh be some funny stuff man
oh my god it'll be funny stuff
and i swear if the cowboys win imma get
this thing oh
i'm calling my suit yeah i'ma have this
custom made for him
this made outfit that he's going nowhere
it's going to cost good money but it's
going to be worth it michael irvin here
on the rich eisen show
now in order for this to happen let's
just say
this year 2021 cowboys picked 10th
overall
i have been pounding the table and tj
jefferson feels i'm doing that just to
get him all riled up and mock him but i
believe this to my core
that if kyle pitts is added to this
offense
as currently constructed and you even
pointed out the mere
hiring of dan quinn to run a scheme that
is more familiar
to this defense than last year's that
might have been the issue and you can
still supplement the defense with other
draft choices
if you can't do that even if it costs
you a one next year to move up the six
spots to
go get kyle pitts at number four overall
the cowboys should do that
what do you think michael irvin
man get cal piss will be insane the kid
just right now looks
phenomenal and everything you know and
you always want to make sure
and i hope and it's like everything that
everything will translate
as he moves to the nfl but
i i rich it has to be at 10
because they need over these next few
years you can't
you know you're gonna you're gonna need
to stop powell that defense if
he falls to ten that's a hard get away
yeah that's not that's hard to get away
that's not happening
that's good right
that's a hard one that's a hard one i i
generally think you move up
quarterbacks if you got a quarterback um
like that
and and then last year a guy fell to us
that we added to that offense
you know what i'm saying so to put that
kind of resource in it i i i really like
certain
i do i really like patrick's day 10 and
locking down
the back end and hopefully going back to
the old scheme help you get more
pressure
like you did a previous year on the
quarterback
and now you got the start of something
good this is about attitude
it's about attitude and i like the kid
and the attitude that he brings
but what about jerry being investigated
i don't love cal poly no i know
i don't look out there no you're being
sensible
you're being sensible that's the
sensible approach but
i don't know if that is what's called
for right now
you know as stephen a pointed out zeke's
diminishing return since signing that
big contract coming off of cabo can not
be denied
i don't know how long with dak making
the coin that he's making now that you
can have a
20 million year receiver i'm i'm not
biting on that
eye i'm not biting on that too you know
you're talking about
his diminishing returns from zeke i'm
not biting on that that offensive line
has been in shambles now if you want to
say
that that offensive line has caused some
diminished returns from zeke
i can say okay to that i will say okay
to that but i'm not buying into
and we know you know tyrone those guys
got hurt
you know uh travis frederick all those
guys
so so yeah i can buy that but just to
put all of this on see
that's insane it's insane i don't think
that's right
so i so i don't i don't necessarily and
all of a sudden since he got that money
since he got paid now we started looking
for no
let's let let's get let's get this
offensive line back healthy
or somewhat healthy and in a better
position
and then and we're spreading out
offenses now that we got a cd
lamb and now you put zeke
back in the back or the health officer
line in a spread out offense
and and you've got you're running
against db's and study the
13 people they've been having on the
offensive line wait no geek to run the
football
they've had 13 people do you do you know
that
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know kyle pitts would just open
that thing up you could win everything
40 to 20 something
it's the shiny toy it's a hard thing and
jerry knows
offense that sells jerseys and kyle pins
coming up and
if they can use and use them correctly
getting him is one thing
you got to be make sure you can use them
correctly
you know if you can get get get get out
of him what they get out of travis
kelsey or george kittle and that kind of
stuff
it'll be incredible it'll be incredible
but but they need so much help on that
defense did i see
cd lamb is going to tap out of the 88
club because they're letting receivers
wear single digits did i see that
is that true yeah i thought i saw
something about that i don't you know he
may get a chance to go back to his
number two
but uh yeah yeah i i don't know i don't
know how that's going
out but you can't do that you can't tap
out of the 88 club right once you're in
you're in
you can't do that well yeah yeah but but
now if
if they drive cow pits he must tap up
and we pass that thing on hope
i knew you wanted him look at you being
so sensible
i knew you were laying in the weeds
damn straight you'd let a tight end wear
88 yes you would
he's a bad boy that would be a perfect
situation that would be a perfect
situation because we want everybody to
have what they want you know i know
i talked to cd lamb how important he how
much he loved that number two even
before
right he put 88 on his back so i
wouldn't take any hard to that you know
what i'm saying
but but but but then what you're gonna
do with that eight
eight we want to make sure we give it to
the pig that'd be cow pit
well that thing now would be whoa
that would be fun too all right irv i'm
gonna register i'm gonna i'm gonna be
dreaming uh
okay hey look i i will let you uh i will
let you
have the same mic drop uh as steven a
because he went on for like 40 minutes
and then
and then ripped your suits and and even
intimated your hair
um is not
oh my god it's not real michael and you
know you [ __ ] me rich are you joking oh
my god
yeah we came up with that picture did
you put that on here
there it is right there
until tufo says it looks like you're
giving us the news at six
like it's yeah you look like a local
news guy on
oh my gosh there it is again now you're
on the phone uh but here
it's our it's it's your identifier for
the moment um
but you know yeah earth i would
certainly
i would certainly i i there's nothing
fake or no wig about my head
but if my head went bald like that i
would
certainly put on a wig
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know there's no question there they
receiving a man you know
that now this account this is the
situation uh
tj where stephen a you know wishes
so so they said everything right here
the cowboys it's some real hate in there
because
what he had to endure his whole life but
but when it comes to this hair thing oh
i'll stop playing now y'all stop playing
i won't let you know i had nothing to do
with that man i'm like put some this is
a three-time super bowl winning
champion we got coming over multiple
emmys and i looked like this
this is michael irvin this is the
playmaker how dare we disrespect man i
wake up every morning
i'm working out i work hard it just
looks
funny with it with the hair going like
that it just don't look right
this is just look right well i mean he
went with the suits too
and that's your that's your calling card
i mean we all have calling cards
so i don't i mean he really went all i
mean we were like wow
okay 40 minutes in and then you just
dropped that mic
all right so just to um yeah although i
love steve
that's my dude i know he felt the same
way so just to recap
to recap um you know steven a is jealous
um about the cowboys success because
it ruined his time in philadelphia and
he's from hollis queens and you
i forget what's the phrase that you use
that you hit them in the behind or
something like that
i forgot what you said yes
however i said it you know that's what
we did you know everything
right it's really coming from our uh our
our upbringing
and just think about that upbringing yep
and that's what he's been doing
he heard it all his young life and now
he's in the business and hearing it all
like
and he can't have a show they would not
have one first take without a cowboy
topic
without a cowboy how many of the first
takes have they gotten through without
eagles topic a giants topic how many
unplanned
they never got to one without a cowboy
stop
so they love they love having the
cowboys name in their mouths on first
take so that's number one
number two is the cowboys can win it
this year they they
they defensively patrick certain you
like him a lot they should stay there
they shouldn't give up anything for kyle
pitts
but if they do give them 88 if cd lam
wants to tap out
right that's you have summed this up
perfectly okay
okay very good um very good and your
hair is real
and steven a is jealous of that too yeah
yeah that that takes a nice chunk out of
the pie
very good okay so jerry jones is chimed
in as well very good
all right irv good luck love you we'll
chat soon
that's very good how you've intertwined
all of this
that's my job you know that you know
that across me great job eddie
a great job man but as steve and they
said i said on that show
some dallas cowboys will be looking so
fine and so far
i'm just letting you know about this
indeed i'll be there too michael irvin
everybody round of applause for my uh
playmaker the playmaker love you take
care of
i put it nice michael here
wow
texted him the uh photograph of uh of
him without hair
in the commercial bracelet is that on tv
right now
take that off take that off tv
oh you're wrong coming up the local news
from democracy with michael irvin
michael irvin live local and
late-breaking
this is channel 7 albuquerque there you
go very good michael irvin camp irvin
here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here